Hello. This is Six Minute
English from BBC
Learning English.
I'm Neil. And I'm Georgie. Now,
if I told you
I'd been for a walk to see Big Ben
and Buckingham Palace,
you'd know straight away
I was in London.
But what if my walk went past
cafes selling mozzarella and ricotta,
where I smelled freshly
made canollis and focaccia...
Where would I be then?
Focaccia and mozzarella…
Well, you'd be in Italy. Right.
Yes, Italy, or Little Italy, to be exact –
the neighbourhood in some cities
where Italian communities settled
and made their home.
These Italian arrivals opened shops
and cafes selling food
to their own communities.
Soon dishes like spaghetti and meatballs
attracted the attention of local people
and gradually Italian food became famous
around the world. In this programme,
we will be taking a walk through
two Little Italy's, one in Argentina,
the other in New York, and,
as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But before that, I have a question
for you, Georgie.
According to a recent YouGov poll,
which Italian food is most popular
with British diners? Is it a) pizza
b) lasagne or c) garlic bread?
I think it must be pizza.
OK, Georgie. I'll reveal the answer
at the end of the programme.
One country
Italians moved to was Argentina.
In 1898,
Giuseppe Banchero arrived in
the neighbourhood of La Boca,
the Little Italy of Buenos Aires,
where many Italian immigrants
started restaurants. Here,
Hugo Banchero, grandson of
Giuseppe, tells his story to
Veronica Smink, reporter for BBC
World Service Programme,
The Food Chain:
Well, my grandfather came from
Italy, from Genoa, from Liguria.
He was born
in the centre of Genoa
and arrived here in
1898 at the age of
seven and a half, and this
pizzeria where we are
was founded on March 28, 1972.
We have been here
for 91 years.
So what culinary traditions
did they bring with them?
Well, our
culinary tradition
is pizza,
and we incorporated the
fainâ from Genoa, which is a
pizza with chickpea flour…
In 1898,
Giuseppe founded his pizzeria –
a restaurant selling pizza. When
a business is founded, its established –
someone starts it up or sets it up.
Giuseppe brought the culinary
traditions from his home in Liguria
in northern Italy, including regional
pizzas like fainâ and furgazzetta.
The adjective culinary describes
anything connected with cooking.
But probably the best-known
Little Italy in the world is an area
of Manhattan's Lower East Side
in New York. 90% of Italian
immigrants who arrived in the US
at the turn of the century
came through this neighbourhood.
De Palos,
one of the original shops selling
Italian food in Little Italy,
has been serving customers
for 113 years. Here, Lou De
Palo, co-owner and great-grandson of
the original owner, Salvino,
explains more
about his family history to BBC
World Service Programme,
The Food Chain:
1925… when my grandmother, Concetta,
and my grandfather, Luigi,
got married, they
opened their own shop…
it's the shop we continue today
being the fourth generation working
alongside my sister, Maria, my
brother, Sal, and our children,
the fifth generation. Our business has
expanded; expanded to represent
the full food culture
of the 20 regions of Italy.
Little Italy is the stepping stone
of the Italian immigrant.
This is where many of the Italian's
first came through Ellis Island,
and then settled here and then
eventually moved into mainstream America
and throughout the
rest of the country.
Lou De Palo is the fourth generation
of his family to run the shop,
and his children will be
the fifth. Phrases like fourth
or fifth generation
describe the children
of people whose parents immigrated
to a particular country.
After arriving in New York,
many Italian immigrants moved on to
start successful new lives elsewhere.
That's why Lou calls Little Italy
a stepping stone, an experience
that helps you achieve something else,
like a real stepping stone
helps you cross a river. As a result,
Italian newcomers became accepted
in mainstream America, mainstream
meaning the culture and customs
viewed as 'normal' by most Americans.
It seems we owe a lot
to Little Italy.
But we still don't know which food is
most popular here in the UK. Isn't it
time to reveal the answer
to your question, Neil?
Right.
I asked you
which Italian food is most popular
in Britain
and you said pizza,
which would be my guess too,
but is... the wrong answer,
I'm afraid! In fact,
the top choice for Italian food fans
here in the UK is garlic bread.
Right, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learned from this programme
on Little Italy,
starting with pizzeria,
a restaurant that sells pizza.
If something is founded, it's
started or established.
The adjective culinary describes
anything connected with cooking.
Phrases like fourth or fifth
generation describe the children
of people whose parents immigrated
to a particular country.
A stepping stone is an event
or experience that helps you advance
or achieve something new.
And finally, the adjective mainstream
describes the customs and culture
which are accepted as 'normal' by
most people in a society. Once again
our six minutes are up. Until
the next time here at 6 Minute
English, it's ciao!
Ciao!